بوصول هذه الطائره والطائره اللاحقه بعد
ساعات من الان نكون الحمد لله استكملنا
الجزء الاكبر من اجلاء معظم مواطنينا من
السودان في اكبر عمليه اخلاء صراحه نقوم
فيها توجيهات جلال سيدنا ربنا يحمينا
للبدايه كانت ان نكرس كل امكاناتنا من اجل
اخلاء كل مواطن اردني وضمان وصوله وصولها
الى ارض الوطن امين سالمين غانمين الحمد
لله
من يومين من اجلنا حوالي مايزينا 340
مواطن اضافه الى مواطنين من جنسيات اخرى
اليوم حوالي 90
شخص كان على هذه الطائره وايضا الطائره
اللاحقه
تقل مواطنين اردنيين ومواطنين غير اردنيين
من اجل ايصالهم الى الى بلدهم ان شاء الله
في رحله قادمه الان كما قلت اليوم ان شاء
الله نكون استكملنا اخلاء العدد الاكبر من
الاردنيين كل من تواصل مع المعانى وكل من
تواصلنا معه
واراد ان نقوم باخلاقه الحمد لله تم
اخلاقه طبعا بتنسيق وجهود كبيره من نشامى
الجيش العربي سلاح الجو الملكي من كل
مؤسسات الدوله الاردنيه احنا كما تعرفون
كنا شكلنا خليه ازمه من البدايه منذ ما
قبل حتى اندلاء العمليات العسكريه لصحنا
مواطنينا بالمغادره بعد الاحداث المؤسفه
في السودان التي نامل ان تنتهي كان هنالك
خليه ازمه على مستوى الوطن توجيهات جلاله
الملك حفظه الله كانت ان نكرز كل
الامكانيات لاجلال اي صفقات المواطنين
الاردنيين ولكن ايضا كل من يحتاج الى عون
ومساعده
والان العدد الاكبر تم اجلائه كل من تواصل
مع الخارجيه واراد ان يتم اخلاقه تم
اخلاقه السفاره موجوده وباقيه في السودان
الى حين اخلاء اخر مواطن اردني اود ان
اؤكد مره اخرى بان هذه عمليه كبيره كل
الدول تتعاون مع بعضها البعض هنالك
مواطنون اردنيون اجليناهم من الخرطوم على
متن طائرات المانيه وهنالك مواطنون المان
وهو لينديون
وايضا اجليناهم عبر طائرات سلاح الجو
الملكي هذه الطائره والطائره اللاحقه
اليوم ستحمل جنسيات عربيه ايضا ما اود ان
اقول اننا نحن في مواجهه اعلى انسانيه
بالنسبه لمواطنين نؤكد بان كل امكانات
الدوله مكرسه بتوجيهات من جلاله الملك
لاجلائهم واخلاهم وصولهم سالمين الى بلدهم
ومواطنون الدول الاخرى كل ما نستطيع ان
نقدمه من مساعده نقدمها في كل ما في كل
الامكانيات
الدول الصديقه والشقيقه الكثير من الدول
جعلت من الاردن قاعده لانطلاق طائراتها
لاخلاق مواطنيها نتعاون بالمطلق معهم كما
قلت هنالك عمليات كبيره المانيا هولندا
دول اخرى كل الدول تتعاون مع بعضها البعض
نحن الان في مواجهه حاله صعبه كل الدول
الشقيقه والصديقه تتعاون تنسق تتبادل
المعلومات وهذا الحد هذا هو المطلوب في
مثل هذه الحاله ما يهمنا هو ان اخلاء كل
المواطنين وايضا نامل ان يتوصل اخواننا
السودانيون الى حل هذه الازمه وقف لعمليه
اطلاق النار حفاظا على السودان وحفاظا على
المواطن
نحن نقوم الان اولوياتنا الان بان اخلاء
المواطنين وكما قلت الكل يريد بهذه الازمه
ان تنتهي وتمت جهود يقوم بها الجميع
شقائنا في الدول العربيه في المجتمع
الدولي هذه ازمه لن تنتج الا المزيد من
المعاناه للشعب السوداني ونامل ان يتوصل
الاخوه السودانيون الى حل ينهي هذه هذه
الازمه ويوقف اطلاق النار
ويحمي السودان من تبعات
المزيد من القتال
الخاصه قالت ان هناك الاوضاع الامنيه تقول
ذلك عندما تسمح الظروف الاردن لم ولن يقصر
توجيهات جلاله الملك دائما ان قلنا مد يد
العون الى كل من يحتاجه اذا كان هنالك
حاجه لمساعدات انسانيه والظروف تسمح بذلك
فالاردن كالعاده سيكون في مقدمه في مقدمه
يقدم هذا المساعدات
[موسيقى]
استقرار السودان وامن السودان مسؤوليه على
الجميع نامل ان يتمكنوا من الوصول الى وقت
لاطلاق النار لمتابعه المزيد
مش
قسميه والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات